foreign
Max is up next in Phoenix Arizona Max
welcome to the Ramsey show my friend how
you doing
good how about yourself doing great
what's your question today
all right so my question it's a little
bit more of a broad one I am just for
context 19 years old
um I do work full-time been working
full-time for the last year and a half I
make about two hundred thousand dollars
a year what do you do
I uh sell cars excellent that's a lot of
cars
yeah how did you do this at 19.
uh really it was just being relentless
um there were a couple programs in my
area I started going investing really
myself uh going to like training
seminars stuff like that and really I
mean I've worked 12 hours a day that
would study four hours a day wow that's
amazing basic selling and um
first year I really struggled and you
know I mean struggles I made 100 Grand
my first year but um quite the struggle
there for it for an 18 year old yeah I
know right wow so that's really good
yeah but now the market shifted and
um again I'm just ready for it and um
now I'm just looking on how I can invest
properly I don't have a lot of depth
um I do have a leased car I've spoken
like a true car salesman right how much
yeah other than the car and I want to
know how much the the car debt is do you
have any other debt
no I have no other Dad I just have rent
okay so just the car lease
correct okay you know this better than
anyone what is the early buyout amount
on that car
30 grand okay
well how much money do you have in the
bank
um well so it'd be just to explain it
better the residual value and it's 30
grand that's the buyout plus what I
currently make payments on which is 20
grand so be a total of 50. oh oh my Lord
that's the full early buy it amount if
you wanted to own this car free and
clear
yes it's a 65 000 car what kind of car
is this
it is a Infiniti Q60 red sport wow sick
Whip and if you oh my goodness well the
good news is as a part of your world and
your income right now it's actually
reasonable if you can continue to make
two hundred thousand dollars
now if you make a hundred thousand next
year we got a problem that's right
right yes I can terminate the lease
early for five thousand dollars and turn
it in tomorrow and forget about it as a
five thousand dollar stupid tax and call
it a day
correct all right you have the money to
pay it off what's the big question
that's on your mind that we can help
with today
really it's just
I'm trying to start saving my money
spending my money a little more wisely
um I have about a hundred grand in the
bank right now what amazing yeah
and I'm trying to learn how to invest
that
it just really get started and I have
deep outside of the car I'm very frugal
saver I know where my money goes but I'm
really I just found days about months
ago so I just started getting into it
I'm probably going to go through uh
Financial Peace here shortly so I'm
really just trying to dial in on this
and figure out how do I invest that
money
so as a car salesman you are you your
own man or are you on
do they offer any benefits towards you
is what I'm asking to to figure out what
your retirement situation looks like
401K they do offer a 401k is there a
match yes
uh 50 sweet is it up to a certain amount
yeah it's up to I believe 20 of your
take home cool wonderful well that's a
great place to start yeah
as far as have you been doing that
yeah I I haven't been doing the full 20
I've been doing about 10 which it is
commission it fluctuates a little bit
um just taking 10 of it a month is
really about a grand two grand a month
give or take huh so we could you could
really walk up the baby steps with this
you know you could make sure that out of
that 100K you're keeping three to six
months of expenses out in your case I'd
go ahead and keep six months out just
because your profession is a little bit
more volatile and there's only one of
you it's only one income so I'd keep six
months of that I would continue to do
the 15 investing and you know do you
have any goals you're 19 are you
thinking about I mean what would you
want to be a homeowner housing wise
yeah I've been I've been looking at it I
mean I just moved to Phoenix about six
months ago
um so I I'm still learning the area very
smart
um moved from Nashville Tennessee
actually right yes very smart keep doing
that keep learning the area give
yourself about a year over there and I
think that you can kind of keep some of
this money stashed away maybe in a good
money market account where it's getting
some interest and when you're ready you
know you're gonna have a nice Hefty down
payment when the time comes yeah I mean
with your income you truly could pay
cash for something if you want to go
real intense but as long as you've got
20 or more down you know with your
situation you could put 10 but you make
so much there's no reason
for the gold get a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage I know that's controversial in
today's society but man when you get a
15 year where the payment is no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay you
have money left over which means you can
live your life you can pay it off early
which means in your 20s you can have a
paid for house think about that that's
right no payments in the world a giant
pile of money in the bank and the rest
of your life ahead of you to continue
investing you could buy more property
with cash you can just the world is your
oyster at that point and Max no more
leases no all right that was it we
learned the lesson the snake bit us
we're not leasing because I want all the
other car salesmen to look at you at 19
making this kind of money with no car
lease and they're going I don't
understand Max leasing is great we this
is what we do for a living and you go
nah dude I found Dave Ramsey I'm trying
to live a debt-free life and they're
gonna look at you going will you show me
how you oh you're in oh wow you're
investing that much you're gonna pay for
a house okay I'm listening to Max's plan
now all right I love it go dude that's
that's inspiring right there's young
people killing it step it up old people
Max has got you beat all right I'm
talking to me George no I didn't look at
you when I said it I was I was not
making eye contact this is the Ramsay
show